I'm gonna explain to you on what happens
when our incomes double during these
ages before I get into my points I want
you to look at this year so basic art so
think about what events take place to us
from 12 16 24 30 35 years old right
around here the income stays flat but
what events takes place the most here
this is when our income has grown the
fastest what happens we are in so many
situations where we have to change we
are forced to learn think about it
you're watching this if you have a
parent you and I didn't have a choice to
go to school when we were 8 years old or
12 years old or 10 years old we were
forced to go to school we were almost
forced to improve it was not a choice
then you go into college I'll never
forget the first time I went to college
my professors name was Van Damme that
was his name he didn't look like Van
Damme but his name was Van Damme right
and me and my friend are sitting right
next to each other it's me Arman and
another guy named Koga Koga and I work
with at Burger King years ago and Arman
owns Raffi's place and we're sitting
there here's this opening line
how many freshmen is in a room would put
our hands up hey freshmen is just so you
know this is no longer high school it's
College which means I don't care if
you're tardy I don't even care if you
don't show up because it's college you
have to have responsibility for yourself
so I look at my friend Arman so everyone
did you hear what he just said right
yeah I heard do SS let's test them
tomorrow let's not show up guess what we
didn't show up the next I'm a terrific I
don't show up the entire semester I got
a W from the guy like freedom I don't
have to show up to class right but we
were forced to improve here then the
choice hits you then we have to choose
to improve and most of us when the
choice is on us we kind of go on coast
mode we don't longer put that kind of
pressure on ourselves or an adult I
don't have to be in that kind of
pressure type situation in our high
school is competitive entire school
systems competitive you can see having
to change yourself to get better income
growth then eventually we get to
opponent we don't want pressure anymore
we stay cruise control so watch this
your point number one about doubling
your income our income doubles the most
when we recreate ourselves the most if
you recreate yourself you get new
results if you stay the same person old
results this mode is constant recreation
mode how many times did you go to school
in high school
there was a kid that was alert nerd the
year before think about it how many
times you went to high school when the
kid was a nerd the year before and then
all of a sudden he shows up the next
year he went from nerd to being cool
what happened there
offseason maybe he decided to get a
girlfriend offseason maybe he started
lifting weights offseason maybe he took
some boxing classes and then he comes
back walking like this in the 11th grade
you were nerd last year what happened to
you he recreated himself but that
doesn't happen too often when we get
here we're the same from 40 to 55 65
years old you recreate yourself and
again recreate yourself then again
recreate yourself how many do you have a
friend maybe you have a friend that you
haven't seen for like a year and you see
your friend and what do you say I don't
recognize this guy he recreated himself
she recreated herself if you your income
earlier when we said what's your income
this year versus five years ten years if
data hasn't changed dramatically and
you're 45 watching this 45 35 it's about
the same you have not recreated yourself
lately
you're pretty much the same person you
were 10 years ago and if you want new
results you got to recreate yourself
it's almost gotta be the measurement
like this Thanksgiving you see your
friends and family you haven't seen them
for six months some of them gotta say I
don't recognize you your family reunion
you have you go to once here I don't
recognize you Christmas I don't
recognize your school reunion I don't
recognize you there's got to be a part
of requite recreation in order for your
income to double